- Before we say goodbye,
y'all, I have one last story
from the world of social
media, this is What I'm Liking.
(audience cheering)
November is National
Family Caregivers Month,
which recognizes the 53
million people who provide care
to an elderly or disabled loved one.
It's stressful and often isolating work,
something author, Debbie
Weiss, can relate to.
For over 40 years, she
cared for her father,
then her son, and finally her husband.
It's a story she shares in her new book,
On Second Thought...Maybe I Can.
Let's get Debbie in here, everybody.
Give it up for Debbie.
(audience cheering)
Hi Debbie.
- Hi Kelly.
- Well, thank you for joining
us and, and I just have to say
you're, you've been a caregiver
your whole life, right?
- My whole life, you said it.
40 years.
I was thrust into
caregiving when I was 17,
when my father, at 46,
had a massive stroke,
became permanently disabled,
and soon afterwards, my parents divorced
and I became his primary
caregiver for the next 30 years
and then when my oldest son was two,
he was diagnosed on the autistic spectrum
and added anxiety and
depression a little later on
and more recently, about five years ago,
my husband became permanently disabled
and unfortunately passed
away on December 30th.
- [Kelly] Oh God.
- And I've spent the majority
of my life caring for others
and after many years,
I was exhausted, angry,
resentful, and bitter
and I hate to admit it,
but I felt sorry for myself
and I then realized that
I was feeling this way
because I neglected myself
for all those years and-
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
- That realization was a
big game changer for me.
- [Kelly] Yeah,
so that change then
created this book, right?
- [Debbie] It has been a long
journey over the last 10 years
that actually led to the book, yes.
- Absolutely.
What do you hope people,
when they read it,
what do you hope they get out of it?
- [Debbie] Oh, goodness.
Well, I hope they learn
what I eventually did,
that prioritizing your
own care is not selfish.
It's a necessity and when we do that,
we actually show up as better caregivers
and just better people for
everyone else in our lives.
You know, we don't really have to choose
between ourselves and our loved ones.
We all have the capacity to care for both.
- [Kelly] Absolutely.
The, I would say it's
the oxygen mask mentality
when you're on the airplane.
You know, they always tell
you, okay, put yours on first
and then help, you know, your little ones
and that's hard to implement in life,
especially if you've
grown up with, you know,
being told like, have a servant's heart,
always look out for others
and you always put yourself aside.
It's kind of how I grew up as well,
and it's hard to change, to pivot that.
Thank you so much, Debbie.
I'm liking your post right now.
(audience cheering)
And that's not all, ma'am.
Our season long partner,
Pilot pen, makers of FriXion,
the go-to race erasable pen
of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
love your support for caregivers.
So on your behalf,
they're writing Family
Caregivers Alliance a check
for a thousand dollars.
For more than 40 years,
this organization has
provided services and support
for caregivers like yourself,
so thank you so much for
putting 'em on everybody's radar
to pay attention to.
(audience cheering)
Thank you, Debbie.
Before we go, I wanna remind you to watch
the 91st Christmas in Rockefeller Center
tomorrow night at 8:00.
I am hosting and will also be performing
alongside a star studded lineup.
It airs on NBC and Peacock,
so be sure to check it out.
It's gonna be incredible.
Thanks to all our guests
this hour, everybody.
Mark Harmon, Kel Mitchell,
Aaron, Zach, and Lanita
and Debbie, of course.
Y'all have a great day and if
it's not, try and change it.